marcus he really is just trying to
continue what the mets starting pitching
has done last 10 games 7-1 and 1.43 and
he's got a stretch now where he's gone
seven straight starts with six innings
or more longest stretch of his career in
that regard bryant back in the lineup
chris will hit a line drive base hit
left center field over to pick it up is
pilar
and bryant welcome back chris he missed
only one game after being hit by a pitch
in his first at-bat on tuesday night by
right-hander taiwan walker but that
swing looked like he felt just fine
thank you so brian aboard with one out
and now it's baez to the plate hobby
it's just 103 in june
that's drilled out towards center field
well struck pilar back at the wall and
it's into the apple a no doubter
baez absolutely clobbers one his 16th
and they jump out front it is two
nothing o2 to contreras and he takes
strike three call the two seamer on the
outside edge but in the inning the cubs
jump on top two runs on two hits the
homer by baez
keeping the ball in the park has been
the challenge for tonight's cub starter
kyle hendricks who in 13 starts covering
74 and two-thirds innings has given up
19 home runs more than any other pitcher
in baseball but this is a guy who's a
good pitcher has been for a while in
fact he's seven and one over his last
eight starts switch hitter batting left
and the one one hit in the air towards
right center hustling towards the gap
heyward he won't get it it's in for a
hit karim's up against the wall at the
380 mark going to second and stopping
there with a lead off double is jonathan
vr
two two to the door breaking ball in
their strike three calls he floated that
one up there and lindor just stood there
could not pull the trigger and down he
goes strikeout number one for kyle see
what he goes with here alonzo waits
and he got him to chase on the curb
struck him out and down goes alonso out
number two strikeout number two for kyle
hendricks beautiful pitch three and one
and that one caught at first by rizzo
the mets squander a lead off doubled by
vr we go to the second inning jake
mariznick former met he's got three out
of six again strowman on the outside
corner and mariznick's caught looking
second strikeout for strowman both on
the same pitch now the o2
is in there strike three called he got
him with a fastball side retired and
that'll bring up billy mckinney mckinney
has a home run in his career against
hendricks and three at bats
and he drives this one deep toward the
gap in left center that's going to split
the outfielders and go to the wall
and mckinney cruises into second base
with a well-struck double here's the 2-2
to peraza strike three call bullseye
fastball knee-high outside corner
mets don't score marcus strowman back to
work
got in on peterson that one lifted out
to left vr can't get it and peterson
racing for a second and jock
able to
find his way to second base and lead off
a man in scoring position pitch swinging
a miss strike three strowman with a
slider
cuts down bryant fourth strikeout for
marcus first one swinging strowman's
pitch rizzo harris it toward left center
smith is over toward the gap makes the
catch on the run and retires rizzo rizzo
hit it hard but dominic smith shifted
over to the gap in left center marcus
strowman first up against kyle hendricks
here's the o2 curve swinging a missed
strike three strollman is gone that's
out number one fourth strikeout for kyle
hendricks and the pitch on the way it's
in there for strike three call
that was a sinker it started inside it
snuck over the inside corner at the last
instant and vr is caught looking
and door swings and misses on a chain
jump in the dirt kyle has just struck
out the side runner in scoring position
with two out 3-2 to alcontra
right back to strowman
and the gold glover makes the play side
retired so marcus strowman works around
a base hit and a wild pitch he leaves
hayward at third and now two on nobody
out for james mccann here's the one two
here's the ground ball to short baez
goes to second there's one over to first
that's a double play
six four three twin killing nicely
turned by alcantara at second here's the
old one
fastball bounced out in front of the
plate bare-handed by contreras throws to
first inning over
good play by contreras he had to run
about 45 feet toward the mound he bare
handed the ball on the run made the
sidearm throw to rizzo and it gets
mckinney and the mets get nothing great
job by hendricks hendricks leads off the
fifth against stroman the one-two on the
way and that's on the outside corner
strike three calls so strowman has his
fourth strikeout
one away it'll bring up jack peterson
the payoff pitch lifted in the air to
deep center back goes pallar out of the
track in front of the fence he jumps and
he makes the catch right at the top of
the wall
right along the orange stripe
above the 408 mark in straight away
center field and that wasn't going to
get out but still it's just the mets
defense just continues to shine 1-2
coming to bryant
and he got him looking
side retired
six strikeouts for marcus nothing across
with some help from pillar kyle
hendricks so far has puzzled the mets
through four innings they only have two
hits
the one-two is swung on and missed
strike three hands over the head the 1-0
chop to hendricks
transit third base side throws to first
stroman is retired a one two three
inning and as he does uh get ready to
work the bottom half of the six ryan
taperos starts to loosen in the cubs
bullpen hubs lead two-nothing francisco
lindor hits a fly ball to center routine
for marisnick backpedaling and squeezing
for out number two
here comes the o2 pitch on the way
bounce slowly to a charging bios gloves
it on the short hop running throw to
first to get him beautiful play by javi
and hendricks works a one two three
inning excellent defensive play by
javier bios marcus strowman back to the
mount for the seventh inning two two
pitches swung and fouled into the glove
of mccann strike three eight strikeouts
to match his season high
line nice stop by alonso he'll got to
take it himself and he does
highway robbery by pete alonso
taking a basement away from sergio
alcantara and getting strowman through
the top of the seventh as peter lonzo
made a tremendous diving stab on a
short-hopped rocket off the bat of
sergio alcantara and with a dive to
first he beat alcantara to end the
inning and ryan tapara who's had an
outstanding year comes on to pitch the
eighth of the cub yeah he's on quite a
streak too 16-game score of the streak
spanning 17 in the third innings and now
the 2-2
fastball strike three called and pillar
knew it immediately he didn't even wait
for the umpire gibson to
yell out strike three he just started
walking toward the mets first base
dugout cubs two mets nothing two down
eighth inning nobody on the strike two
stretch and the pitch
bounced right back to the mound easy
play to para torizo and that's that
let's go one two three excellent job by
topera
craig kimbrell has been outstanding this
season the bearded veteran right-hander
trying to nail down the save and now the
stretch for the 3-2 here it comes to vr
swinging a missed strike three
fastball got him and the 3-1
bouncing ball the shortstop buyers
off-balance long throw got him what a
play by javi
that's down to their last strike here
comes the 2-2 from kimbrell swaying in a
miss strike three in the ball game is
over
the chicago cubs win it by a score of
two to nothing craig kimbrell with
another save